el niño pensé que cuando creciera iba a
ser una persona grande
terminé midiendo metros 60 metros 63 de
altura los contar con 2 metros 67 pensé
que iba a tener una dieta llena de
dinero la verdad es que hay pura polilla
pero configuraba solita y recibos que
veo a la gente pensé que iba a viajar
por el mundo europa africa australia a
cualquier lado terminé yendo solo de mi
casa al trabajo de mi trabajo a mi casa
nada más entonces muchos irán este pata
es un fracasado es un complacido
realmente no nos pida para más pero la
verdad es que dentro de todo esto
aprendí a ver qué es una vía simple poco
lujo cosas
tener pocas cosas en la vida realmente
me hacía más feliz que ser una persona
digamos que compra y con bastante dinero
entonces bueno yo estudié ingeniería
agrícola en la universidad agraria una
que academy carrera y me fui a
inglaterra a hacer un posgrado el
posgrado eran química supramolecular en
la especialidad de química tenor no
dinámica y bueno yo estuviese esa
carrera y realmente no gustaba pero lo
decía asumir como un reto porque
realmente mi abuelo fue científico
entonces yo quería hacer lo mismo
entonces decidí terminar
y la carrera
terminé al día siguiente ya me volví a
perú porque realmente extrañaba bastante
mi país quería hacer algo dentro de mi
país entonces volví pero terminé en la
cocina
de mi padre lavando platos usar platos
porque en verdad no quería imprimir un
cb un currículum vítae de 34 líneas de
experiencia laboral iba a ser ridículo
no entonces lo más simple era aprovechar
la vara que tenía en el negocio mi padre
y auto contratarme
entonces me puso un plato y aprendí
bastante aplica bastante en lo que el
sistema de riego usa para lavar los
platos
el riego tecnificado entonces
bueno dentro cuando comencé a trabajar
ahí poco a poco me fui metiendo de
diferentes lados de la cocina y aprendí
bastante y me en cuenta que todo lo que
había estudiado los la química la
ingeniería me ha ayudado bastante a
comprender el entorno en que estaba en
lo que pasaba en las sartenes en la
tabla de picar todo entonces valore
mucho lo que había aprendido no fue un
tiempo perdido una cantidad de dinero
desperdiciada en mis estudios sino ayuda
a forjar mi conocimiento mi persona y mi
carrera como cocinero entonces me gustó
todo esto y bueno también me di cuenta
que tener un restaurante
digamos de precios un poco más elevados
en lo normal que eran la carta de mi
padre no eran que son muy baratos
cada vez se limitaba mucho al acceso a
otras personas a que puedan probar
nuestra comida entonces y eso seguía que
los costos eran altos en los insumos
aparte bastantes cosas que no tenían
nada que ver con la comida que sólo eran
gastos tipo de manteles lavandería cosas
que distan mucho del plato entonces me
decía por qué pasa esto también me di
cuenta que realmente habían muchos
gastos de espacio atención y
prácticamente eras esclavo del cliente
no el cliente sea como podría pagar buen
dinero está diciendo yo quiero que me
cocine si esto ha sido así así y métele
esto y esto no le pongas y realmente eso
te en tema logra todo el plato lo está
destruyendo y tiene que volver a hacer
un plato solo para esa persona mientras
que tienes otras 20 personas pidiendo
entonces gastas tiempos destrezas
y realmente viviendo quería eso yo
quería algo simple y por eso después de
hablarlo con mi madre decidimos abrir al
toque pese al toque pues es un concepto
de comida rápida y barata y sobre todo
rico no inspiraba bastante en la comida
de ambulante del mercado quería una
rotación fuerte como las que ellos
tenían y para eso tenía que vender a
precios más cómodos entonces hicimos una
barra con sólo seis asientos los
asientos eran chiquitos y comían la
gente así y recontra incómodos para que
se vayan rápido y realmente es un sin a
declaración a un motor horrible que
parecía tan que el motor depende
malogrado y suena para cuando la
comprendemos la gente se asusta y bueno
eso fue ese salto tiempo
digamos un local con poco almacenamiento
entonces como todos usamos todos los
insumos para todos los platos entonces
se acaba rápido o sea tenemos alta
rotación de nuestros insumos
buscamos insumos que no sean caros
insumos como la pota el perico la lisa
cosas que mucha gente no valora porque
piensa que es barato que está tienen una
mala reputación nosotros lo hacemos lo
transformamos en algo increíble y creo
que ese es una de las cosas bonitas del
toque porque me han enseñado bastante a
trabajar con diferentes insumos e ir al
mercado o buscar todo lo que hay ahí
entonces de esa manera no solamente he
crecido como empresario en verdad no
creció nada como empresario pero se ha
hecho conocido me ve la marca sino he
crecido como persona porque malo mamá
nada dado la capacidad de aprender
muchas cosas que no iba a lograr la
resonante en mi padre
bueno en esa época cuando yo empecé al
toque pues la mayoría de la gente quería
hacer un restaurante grande y lujoso
todo eso entonces yo sé prácticamente lo
contrario
en verdad no tenía nada que perder y sé
algo totalmente distinto y la gente lo
vio y peor o sea dijo que raro porque
esta persona que trae gente restaurante
ahora hace una cosa que totalmente
y forma todo raras y simple trabajando
con cosas baratas entonces ahí comenzó a
llegar gente prensa
gente vinculado todo el ámbito
gastronómico y se hizo popular mi
restaurante entonces no me equivoqué por
ese lado me fue bien pero muchos de
ustedes se preguntarán qué mérito tiene
todo esto sí porque me gusta tanto
trabajar ahí sí entonces tan simple es
cortar o puedo está pescado y meterla
mezclarlo y está ya es mentira porque si
te pones a analizar todo lo que pasa ahí
es realmente un mundo viendo información
lleno de procesos cosas que puedes
aprender de a poco a poco seamos como el
hombre hormiga y nos metemos al mundo
cuántico al mundo de las moléculas
chiquitas átomos y todo esto ya y como
ejemplo vamos a regar el arroz con
marisco tenemos nuestra sartén es como
un sistema dejamos que caliente bastante
para que evitar que las cosas se peguen
para que todo el agua que se acumula
dentro de la sartén dentro de los poros
en la sartén se evapore la gramos el
aceite dejamos que caliente bien hasta
humedad los monos siempre para que
quedaron la pátina de grasa que emite
también que las cosas se peguen cuando
solo una superficie húmeda a una sartén
seca se apegaron con esta patina que no
se pega entonces una vez que estén ambos
bien calientes le agregamos los mariscos
junto al soundcloud o el pimiento a la
sal y la pimienta no y ahí es cuando
comienza a suceder todo esta magia nos
movemos en la sartén y a la hora de
mover incorporamos oxígeno dentro de el
sistema que hace cuando hay un incendio
en tu casa se está quemando algo lo peor
que vas a hacer es meterle aire nunca
sople nada desgarrar la arena por lo
paso en un material que no sea
combustible pero nosotros porque hacemos
que entre oxígeno que es altamente
combustible porque queremos que se
prendan que explosión de todo entonces
al hogar explosionar hace que los
sabores salgan de los mariscos o sea que
todo se integre no ls aumento todo rico
se produce una reacción que se llama
reacción de my life' en la superficie de
los mariscos
es una reacción entre los óxidos lípidos
o las grasas el marisco y también de las
proteínas y los caminos de las
superficies y se crea un par de ambiente
de la superficie y eso es lo que le da
ese sabor tan rico especial por ejemplo
al bistec al cuerpo al pollo la grasa se
está capa doradita eso se llama reacción
de myler no entonces una vez que
comienzas a saltear esto lo apagas
dándole vino siempre recomiendo
agarrarlo con espesor porque mientras
más gotitas pequeñas salga el mismo
hacia la sartén más rápidos a cobrar y
si más rápido se evapora no va a tener
ese sabor digamos alcohólico sino a
tener ese sabor equilibrado entre ha
sido un poco dulce no entonces le
agregamos eso le agregamos el caldo de
pescado el alcohol del vino con la grasa
del pescado van a interaccionar no se va
el alcohol va a ayudar que esa grasa se
diluya dentro del caldo y nos vaya a ser
nuestras fosas nasales si no se queda en
el palacio entonces vamos a sentir esos
aminoácidos son utah matos dentro
nuestro balear sin que vaya a nuestro
olfato no entonces una vez que tienes
esto le agregamos el arroz como
cualquier borrachera con vino le tienen
meter un carbohidrato como el arroz el
arroz se va a encargar de chupar todo
sea hidratar el arroz es almidón
entonces a la hora de tener el almidón a
la hora estar en contacto con el agua en
su entorno va a comenzar a hidratarse a
hincharse no entonces el sabor es la sal
el agua con la sal todo de este sistema
se va a mantener en los micro poros y
las grasas moléculas más grandes se van
a pegar en la superficie también hay
pedacitos de almidón que quedaron
sobrantes por mito del arroz eso va a
ayudar a que el caldo del arroz con
marisco se espese entonces baleares está
esta textura más quizás un poco más
pegajosa más lee goza la rojo marisco no
hacen una textura seca
entonces bueno si vemos calentando
dejamos que todo esto tenga que se tome
su tiempo que se hidrate todo bonito
rico que es solo en los sabores y se
ritmo si comemos y dirán bueno y con eso
bueno verán que algo tan simple se puede
explicar en con ciertos químicos en
conceptos físicos hasta biológicos y
hace que esta mezcla algo tan simple tan
chiquita a nivel molecular a una
explosión dentro de tu boca pero no todo
es comida ya no se está dando a hombre
quizás hablemos de otras cosas de la
parte fue alto que ves la parte
económica y alcancía está totalmente
vacía es un negocio realmente que no
sería el caso de estudio en como no son
una empresa digamos en el típico o
currículum universitario
mi empresa no sólo estamos le damos
prioridad
al crecimiento horizontal el crecimiento
económico de horizontal queremos que las
personas que contribuyen a esta empresa
los trabajadores los proveedores toda
esta gente que dejan con nosotros no
queremos no somos de los que no queremos
minimizar todos los gastos a éste le
pago eso en contrato de una persona que
no coge mucho contrato compro tal
ingrediente porque madera todo en tal
lugar nosotros queremos que tanto los
clientes se grandes beneficiados como
también nuestros proveedores y los
trabajadores nosotros por ejemplo yo voy
al mercado y nunca me fijo en cuánto
cuesta digamos el kilo de pescado
tampoco me fijo me voy donde el abarrote
no es el otro el otro chico me lo vende
a dos soles menos mientras que ellos me
convienen el precio justo
porque hay que reconocer que esa persona
está madrugando para traerte el insumo
bueno no a la puerta de tu local pero
sigue a su stand hace un esfuerzo
entonces hay que saber recompensarlo no
todo es ganancia para uno tienes que
saber respetar eso y tener y aprender a
alimentarte la felicidad de saber que tú
estás colaborando para que esa persona
también salga adelante entonces eso es
para mí lo más importante al toque pues
no poder hacer que no solamente yo me
beneficié sino que todo el mundo a mi
alrededor se beneficia igualmente no
hacer que el barrio donde yo estoy
crezca a la vez y de esa manera todo el
entorno se ve con la mano más bonito yo
creo que al final eso es lo que hace que
un local chico como alto que pese logre
hacer un local en verdad grande
muchas gracias
ah